follow your heart whenever you're faced
with a major decision in your business
or your life the most important thing
that you can do the best decision to
make is to follow your heart and not
your head the reason why it's so
important is because your head it's
logical it's rational and if you're
making a decision it always revolves
around the world that currently exists
it's a concrete world I can't fathom
creating something new because I
wouldn't be logical you can't think
about a world that doesn't yet exist
because that is not logical that's not
rational
when you think with your heart when
you're following your heart you
understand that you can make any world
you want whatever you want to go and do
you can go and do you can create the
world that you want to live in but
that's not logical that's not rational
if you are making an important decision
if you end up doing something with your
life if you are in a job that is great
with your head right I told you this
makes sense logically but your heart's
not in it you're never gonna be
successful but if your heart is into
something if you're passionate about
something your brain will find a way to
make that work you have to lead with
your heart it's critical at any
important decision in your business or
your life has to be led with your heart
think about a somebody graduating from
school who maybe loves math loves math
and is thinking about should I become an
accountant or should I become a chess
player because I love chess what most
people do
dates say become an accountant because
of thinking with their head they're
making a decision with their brain
because they look at the world that
currently exists and they say hey if
you're an accountant you got a steady
job there's lots of jobs open right now
you have income coming and you can look
after yourself and your family go take
that job if you do that if you're that
kid you're great at math you go and you
take that job as an accountant when you
love chess if you do that route because
people say you should
become an accountant it's the safe route
it makes sense is logical you're never
going to be happy in your career and in
your life you're not gonna be happy
you're doing something only because your
head but not because you feel it you
gotta feel it now I'm not knocking on
accountants if you love accounting if
that's your thing then go out and be the
world's best accountant own it love it
but if you love chess go be a chess
player and people say there's no way to
make money off of chess that doesn't
make sense that's a crazy idea there's a
million ways to make money off the chess
okay if you love this if you're
passionate about it this something that
you were born to do there's a million
different ways to make money off of
being a chess player and you'll have
more success have more money have more
excitement have more happiness in your
life if you follow that Routh become the
chess player instead of going off and
become an accountant this is important I
think about my own life
when I was graduating University okay I
was starting up my business I had my
business start in University and and I
was sucking I was sucking as an
entrepreneur I was I was not getting
anywhere near the results I thought I
was gonna get I'm making $300 a month
failure and when I'm getting to my last
year I got job opportunities with two of
the biggest companies most respected
companies that I wanted to potentially
work for I was looking at Merrill Lynch
and McKinsey Consulting if he wanted to
be an investment banker or if you wanted
to be in Chris to teacher consulting
those are the top two companies and they
came to me they came recruiting me
wanted me to join their companies
looking at everybody in my class they
would die for that opportunity that's
what everybody geared themselves towards
that's what you were trained to want to
go and become you're making six figures
the day you graduate you're traveling
around the world you're closing huge
deals that was the lifestyle everybody
wanted and and I barely put effort into
the interviews and I didn't get the job
because my heart wasn't in it
my heart was in this crappy little
company that wasn't doing anything yet
if I did make that decision with my head
I would have looked at the two scenarios
logically right
the one hand I have this crappy company
I'm barely making any money on it I
don't know if this thing is ever gonna
take off
I have no track record as an
entrepreneur my partner's has never done
anything what makes me think this is
gonna be a success nothing logical
versus six figures travel doing
interesting work why wouldn't I go the
safe route why wouldn't I take that job
because listening to my heart I would
never have thought it would never have
made sense that I would have taken that
company from 300 bucks a month to
building it up to having customers in 30
countries like NASA and Johnson Johnson
to being acquired to then going into a
venture capital company helping raise
millions of dollars for entrepreneurs
and then starting my own venture again
with a goal to help a billion
entrepreneurs to start this movement
around believing in entrepreneurs to
make a real impact to have all the
traction I have gotten so far I would
never have thought of that with my head
and if I did it wouldn't have made sense
if I was going back to my last day of
university and looking at those options
that wouldn't be a smart logical
rational decision you never know the
world that you can create unless you
listen to your heart and I'm so glad I
did because I look at my friends who did
take those jobs ten years later and they
hate their lives they have no family
time they're they're bored with what
they're doing they don't feel like
they're growing they're burnt out
they're stressed out and I'm so glad
that I didn't go that route and at the
time it was it was scary it was stupid
it was crazy
why would I go do this it didn't make
any sense because I was listening to my
heart you have to feel it you have to
feel like you're doing the right thing
and you have to be willing to turn away
people who doubt you right you're gonna
have the non-believers you're gonna have
lots of people who say what are you
doing this is crazy this doesn't make
any sense enough when you listen to your
heart it doesn't make any sense because
you're off creating a world that never
existed before you're creating something
for yourself that the
never happened before you're blazing a
new trail and you're fulfilled and
you're gonna be happy you're gonna make
a lot of money have a lot of success
doing it but it doesn't come easy and it
doesn't make sense to everybody else at
the start and so you have to have the
courage to push through that push
through the naysayers and follow your
heart this whole rant came out of a
question from one of my YouTube viewers
Lindy love you guys who wrote in to say
she's interning at a magazine company
she's an accounting student wants to
know what I think about changing her
degree to journalism she's in her final
year it doesn't make sense to do it or
not first of all doesn't matter what I
think doesn't matter what you think
stop stop being up here listen to your
heart what feels right
do you love journalism if you do that's
the path follow it and it takes guts it
takes courage to start down one path
like you've done with accounting and
then say this is not right for me and
switch it takes a lot of guts because in
the eyes of society you're seeing as a
failure you're seen as someone who
doesn't know what they want you see my
son who's giving up but it's way more
courageous and way more smart to do that
then to continue on this path and hate
your life because society tells you so
so you know Lindy it doesn't matter what
I think
listen to your heart and for those of
you watching you have an important
decision in front of you right now in
your business or your life you're not
sure whether they say yes or no to an
opportunity listen to your heart what
feels right get out of your head because
this isn't going to help you go with
what feels right listen to your heart
and your head will find a way to make it
happen for you believe those are you
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below always next want to do
more for you and let me know what you
think you listen to your head of your
heart put it in the comments below I
want to see your responses those
comments keep me going you have a
question put it below as well make a
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon
you